welcome to this simultaneous meeting of
baba district council cabinet and
mid-suffolk district council cabinet
i am councillor john ward leader of baby
district council and also in attendance
is councillor susie morley leader of
mid-suffolk district council we will be
jointly chairing the meeting today
however for reasons of efficiency i will
be leading the items
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure that your mobile phones
are on silent or switched off
and finally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
so please could members make sure they
are logged in and ready to use the app
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and all
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
i'll now move to the gender
so firstly item one apologies for
absence
good morning chair we have received no
apologies from members but the chair of
paper over you and scrutiny committee
has forwarded her apologies for this
meeting thank you henriette item two to
receive declarations of pecuniary or and
non-pecuniary interests by members are
there any to declare members
nope thank you
item three
paper bca217
to confirm the minutes of the baba
cabinet meeting held on the 2nd of
august
2021.
um you've got that in your agenda pacs
baba members and just quickly going
through page seven
page 8
page 9
page 10
page 11
and
page 12.
so
does any baby member have any points
regarding the accuracy if not may i have
a proposal please
from baber
councillor busby thank you
and a seconder
councillor malvisi thank you
so may we now have the electronic vote
please for the baba minutes
yes members uh the vote is now in
progress on your app
i know
[Music]
chair that is uh
seven votes four and one abstention
thank you
right moving on councilor morley
so to mca 21-16
to confirm the minutes of the
mid-suffolk cabinet meeting held on the
2nd of august 2021
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
can i have a proposal please
counselor heading and a seconder
councillor flatman thank you very much
the government's officer will now
conduct the vote
thank you chair the votes are now in
progress on your app
that is nine watts four that's carried
thank you
okay moving on item four
to receive notification petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received thank you
item five questions by councillors
none received thank you
and item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees
there has no such matter been received
chad thank you
moving on
item seven the forthcoming decisions
list does anyone have any comments about
any of the forthcoming items on the
forthcoming decisions list
you'll see
covering today's meeting castle
and cabinet through to the end of the
year and beyond
any comments
another from cabinets so councillor
mellon
thank you i've got a question on that
item is that okay
yes yes you may ask her um can i ask why
there are no proposals that we can see
coming to cabinet from the forthcoming
decisions list
following the workshops to discuss the
spend of four million pounds set aside
for cross-party agreement
i will pass that to councillor morley
would you like to answer that
we're still having discussions about
what those items might be and
once that's happened then it will be
coming to you back to cabinet
and
once it's gone to my group then it will
be discussed with plg
before coming back to cabinet
castle melon
um just as a supplementary question then
um
our budget proposals were withdrawn back
in the spring
um on the promise that we would get this
four million pounds with cross party
working
the all counsellor workshops were held
in may
the collated ideas were presented to our
group in june
on 9th of july we submitted the
opposition's proposals to the leader and
we'd dearly love to see some progress on
this issue
thank you
sorry councilman i guess that was a
statement rather than a question
does the leader agree it would be good
to see some progress on this issue
we absolutely are making progress thank
you
i think that's a case of watch this
space it's going to be exciting
okay then
if there are no other questions or
comments on the forthcoming decisions
list i'll move on to item eight
which is paper bca2118
and also paper mca 2117 the general fund
financial monitoring for 2021 to 22 the
first quarter quarter one
and so i'll now introduce the report as
the baba cabinet member for finance
so i'm pleased to present report bca
2118 to cabinet which is the general
fund quarter one financial monitoring
for this year covering the revenue and
capital financial performance for the
period april to june 2021 and
highlighting the major variances
compared to the budget that are expected
as with last year's monitoring reports
it also incorporates the upstate impact
of covert 19 on the council's finances
which is continuing this year
this remains difficult to predict and as
throughout last year we continue to
monitor the unplanned costs and loss of
income and report back to the ministry
of housing communities and local
government
the headline at the end of quarter one
i'm pleased to report is that we are
forecasting a surplus of
000 pounds
our budget for this year approved in
february was prepared during a time of
great uncertainty due to covert income
streams were revised to reflect this
with covered related costs assumed to be
financed from the covered reserve
we don't yet know about next year's
spending review or whether there will be
a long-awaited three-year comprehensive
spending review
the one-year review published in
november last year focused on
prioritizing the response to covered and
supporting jobs
the fair funding review business rates
review and business rates reset have
also been delayed
government support for businesses and
workers still continued this quarter
and the table in paragraph 5.2 of your
report shows the amount we have
administered in quarter one
have said the council's finances remain
at risk from the effects of covert we
had 891 000 pounds remaining from
government support funding in 2020 to 21
which we have added to the covert
reserve giving a start of the year
reserve balance of 1.171 million pounds
added to this is 414 000 pounds of
funding received this year
at the moment we anticipate that the
main areas where support will be needed
during 2021-22
are additional costs for public health
leisure and further business support
the full year impact is currently
forecast to be additional costs of 613
000 pounds and a loss of income of 309
000 pounds
the details are provided in the table in
paragraph 5.6
as at the end of the quarter council tax
collection stands at 5.8 million pounds
or 29.43
which is up slightly from 28.7 this time
last year
but the business rates collection rate
is 24.15
which is down from 26.43 for the same
period last year
this will be mitigated by the 133 000
pound compensation payments received
from government last year which is now
in the business rates and council tax
reserve
baseline business rates of 1.6 million
pounds new homes bonus of 835 000 pounds
will forecast in the 21 to 22 budget
the key variations on expenditure and
income compared with budget that have
been attributed to the over overall
variable variance have been identified
and elicited
in appendix a
key points to note are that car parking
income is still lower due to the
lockdown in force during quarter one and
we have reduced the amount of costs
added to outstanding council debt steps
at debts due to unavailability of court
time and the shortfall will be funded
from the covered reserve
on a positive note development
management activity is particularly
strong at the moment with an increase in
post lockdown applications resulting in
additional income
the forecast variances will be taken
into account when sitting next year's
budget
we received 1.807 million pounds of
still income in the first three in the
first quarter of this year
which is up from 1.45
million pounds for the same period last
year
apart from the 5 admin charge this will
be transferred to the earmarked reserve
appendix b shows how we are spending the
100 business rates retention pilot
funding
755 000 pounds is still unspent which
159 000 pounds is as yet unallocated
a report will be prepared for cabinets
setting out proposals for use of the
uncode unallocated balance feasibility
work under the three themes of the
economic strategy and recovery plan
paragraph 6.8 summarizes the currently
predicted movements in the strategic
priorities reserve for the forecast
balance of 647 000 pounds at the end of
the year
at this stage we're not showing a
transfer of any other budget surplus to
this as it is likely along with other
reserve movements to change
the reserve details are provided in
appendix c
and we will continue to review
commitments to ensure that key
priorities are supported
appendix d sets out our general fund
earmarked reserves including forecast
transfers for the year
earmark reserve balances were 7.945
million pounds as of the 1st of april
excluding the 4.541 million pounds
section 31 grants received in 2020 to 21
that will be used to cover the cost of
retail hospitality and leisure release
during this current year through the
collection fund
the end-of-year balance is forecast to
be
6.607 million pounds
transfers are summarized in paragraph
6.11
but i should note that the figure for
the homelessness reserve is 35 000
pounds not the 25 000 pounds as stated
in that paragraph although appendix a
sorry appendix d is correct on on that
number
finally our general fund capital program
is detailed in paragraph 6.12 6.15 and
appendix e
capital expenditure for quarter one
totals 526 thousand pounds against a
revised program including carry forwards
of 20.79 million pounds
now as always always with complex
capital schemes it is difficult to
accurately assess the level of payments
that will be made during the financial
year
the important thing is to focus on
whether outcomes have been achieved by
the capital investment rather than
in-year variances
in addition the profile of the
anticipated spend this year is difficult
to assess at this stage because of the
likelihood of slippage in the delivery
of some programs due to the ongoing
effects of cobit
lastly some items in the capital program
such as the strategic investment fund
regeneration fund and bellevue are
unlikely to be fully spent in year so
the figures anticipate that a request
will be made to carry forward any
unspent balance at year end
i'd like to thank our finance team for
preparing the support and keeping a
strong grip on our finances in what is
still as last year an unpredictable time
before opening up for questions and
debate i'd first like to move the
recommendations in section three of the
report that the council's surplus
position of 261 000 pounds and revised
capital program be noted
and may i have a seconder for this
please
councillor osborne thank you
so um right
i'll now invite the mid suffolk cabinet
member for finance to introduce the mid
suffolk report
so council whitehead
thank you chairman
i'm pleased to introduce report mca 2117
being the general fund financial
monitoring for quarter one which starts
on page 13 of today's mid-separate
cabinet pack
included within the report in section 5
it gives a comprehensive update on
financial impact to the council of cobit
19.
i don't intend to cover this in any
detail in this brief introduction but we
will of course be happy to answer any
questions that members may have on this
matter
at cabinet's august meeting
i presented the outturn for the previous
year 2021
based on final pre-audit numbers
now those post-year-end out-turns are
based on actual historic numbers
in contrast in-ear monitoring and
out-turn forecasts such as one before us
today
are based on actual income and expense
to date in this case to the 30th of june
and then a forward prediction or
forecast for the balance of the year
clearly this early stage of three months
actual and nine months forecast
involves a number of uncertainties of
extrapolations and assumptions about the
future
despite these uncertainties the exercise
is important as it tests where we are
against budget
and involves detailed three-way
discussions between the finance team
budget management managers
and the senior leadership team to
produce the forward forecasts
at this early stage we are forecasting a
surplus position of 103 000
the table and comments in appendix a
provides the analysis and build up to
this figure
broken out into the various areas of
operations and responsibilities
as is typical the biggest positive
driver is strong income in development
control
the report also includes projection of
the growth and efficiency fund showing a
remaining unallocated balance of 1.193
million
and appendix c gives a line-by-line
breakout of our growth and efficiency
fund spend and commitments
appendment appendix d
sets out the movement on
all our earmarked reserves
that table shows a year-end forecast of
19.44 million
but between now and then
anticipate various projects coming to
cabinet for approval for expenditure
from the various 1 million pound pot set
aside for climate change and
biodiversity
well-being economy housing and
communities
we don't take these approvals for
granted prior to them being brought to
cabinet
so they are not yet included within the
table
but clearly they will be coming forward
for expenditure against these headings
and i trust this comment there's some
way to lay council mellon's
concerns that he expressed earlier
the projections within this report also
include capital expenditure
this is set out in the table in appendix
e which shows a comprehensive and
ambitious capital program
so this stage in the year all the detail
is for noting only i'd like to move the
recommendations to that effect set out
in paragraph three
i'd ask for someone to second those
recommendations we'll be happy to answer
any questions members may have on the
detail within the report thank you
chairman
thank you council whitehead
do we have a secondary from midsuffoc
firstly uh questions from baba members
does anyone have any questions on the uh
paper general fund report
council busby
thank you chair yes the uh you talked
about slippage on the capital
expenditure account
do we do we know how that will impact on
borrowing costs for the year
um
um
a second question
i just wonder
council tax how many people do we know
how many people are claiming the 25
single occupancy discount and i wonder
whether there's any
trend in that it might give us an
indication of the kind of houses that we
need to be building or
whether it's going to impact on our
income going forward in terms of your
second question i think that's probably
something we'll have to take away unless
um anyone can answer that immediately no
i didn't expect they would no
um
council before we go back to the first
question castle also you've got your
hand up is that something
yeah in reference to the question
regarding the 25 discount on council tax
i haven't got the answer to the question
but i can go home and find it out
because it will be within the shared
revenue
uh partnership uh report that we get so
by all means i can do that and then
email it out to the rest of the cabinet
we'll certainly get the answer to that
one way or another yeah
um the the first
uh question you had about the borrowing
costs on the capital program
uh again does can anyone from the
finance team
provide
an answer to that please
melissa
thank you thank you
and yeah we'd only actually borrow once
we spent on the capital program so
there's no commitment to to you know pay
interest on any of those loans we
wouldn't commit ourselves to any
borrowing until we'd incurred
expenditure on that capital programme
so there will be a saving
i understand that but
we must have included in the budget an
estimate of how much we would like to
borrow and therefore the potential
borrowing costs
and this will surely be different if we
i mean 20 million quid is quite a hefty
capital expenditure if we're not
borrowing that
that should have quite an impact on the
borrowing caution
we might have to come back on that one
just to check what we put in the budgets
for that
just to make sure
thank you melissa
okay are no further questions from baber
cabinet members oh council busby here
sorry i must have had a boring weekend
yeah um
it's one other thing that we i don't
expect to be answered today but i just
wondered given the fluidity of
staff at the moment
and i see that the figures are broken
down by directorate so the figures are
in there but i just wonder whether we
could have
one section of paper or an email on
the number of staff
by directorate
the number of vacancies by directorate
and the
staff costs by directorate and the
again the vacancy savings by directorate
so it would be
a small table of
eight lines or whatever with four
columns just just to have it on one area
rather than have to
fish around the whole report
i would imagine that would be feasible
yes chief executive is nodding so
definitely yeah we'll we'll make sure
we're getting
we know we've got whatever it is 20
vacancies which seems like an awful lot
but
you know if you've got 20 000 staff not
that we have it isn't
okay thanks counselor
um
moving over to mid-suffolk members any
mid-suffolk members have any questions
on the mid-suffolk general fund report
no
any other members present uh
kate right uh councillor welling you
were first
thank you chesterton yeah
council field then councilman
that's it um
at the last uh covenant meeting up i
asked a question about mid-suffolk
leisure center
and the expenditure thereon or predicted
expenditure thereon and i did have a
response on the 9th of august which
thank you but it just referred to
a condition survey
which was which had been carried out
so is it yet possible to say further
work is needed as a result of analyzing
the condition survey and when will it be
carried out
and
that that was a question about the money
set aside in the transformation fund
uh there's still 286k of that money to
be spent
and it's shown as committed so
has that been allocated to any specific
items of expenditure
is any of it related to safety or energy
efficiency improvements
and in the general fund
there's a total of two million which
appears to be set aside for expenditure
on mid-south leisure center for the
current financial year
um that's 1.337 for improvements and the
rest is for
extension and
repla
refurbishment
do we have any details of what that work
is and
are we confident that it will all be
spent
[Music]
council whitehead well
can i just say i don't have that detail
to hand but i'm hoping one of the
officers might be able to come to my
assistance
apologies we don't have that level of
detail to hand either so i think that's
another one that we'll need we'll need
to take away and provide or provide an
answer to
that's fine thank you
thank you council field you were next
thank you just two points really um
paragraph 5.2 talks about
an amount of grant funding quite
considerable sums remaining i just
wanted to confirm does that
return to the government if we don't get
it spent in some specific time scale
and uh to carry on slightly page 24
there's a
pretty chunky positive variance against
development management
just wondered you know we are supposed
to i guess talk to developers quite
considerably i wonder what we're doing
to improve our forecasting there because
um
among other things that sort of
difference in spend represents a
considerable difference in workload i
would have thought so
we need to
consider doing a bit better
two questions
council whitehead did you want to pick
up on those
yes sir i'm just trying to dig out an
email on the detail about the grants and
which ones are
re-payable and which ones aren't but
perhaps kathy might be able to come to
my to my ad if she has that information
just to handle because i know some are
repayable
and some are not i believe
i might need to defer to my colleagues
either melissa or i think fiona's here
as well they've been heavily involved in
the grant programs
um yeah so there are
broadly two different types of
government grants uh there are some
smaller ones as well but the two main
ones are
different versions of a mandatory grant
that government gave and um not all of
that money
could be spent because some of it
couldn't be paid for example to
companies that reached their state state
aid threshold the government made a sort
of broad brush figure those mandatory
grants my understanding they will have
to be paid back the money that was given
to the councils to spend under the
discretionary fund is all now fully
spent we have spent all of that
does that help
yeah and to the
question about development control
forecasting and the reality is that uh a
lot of the um well the
great amount of the
positive variance comes from additional
income it is a difficult area to
to forecast and thinking back to several
years ago we had a group
away day for budgeting and we gave each
other a challenge to come up with a
forecast based on looking at historical
data and i think the range of income was
something like 800 000 to 2 million it
really is
it's very difficult to
to forecast the future
development income even with the
greatest amount of
discussions with developers but and i
think um
people just generally are tend to be
cautious when creating a budget because
positive viruses are
preferable to adverse ones but in terms
in terms of staffing implications i
don't know whether the chief executive
or
all of the ads would like to
answer that
thank you council and i think it's
probably fair to say that there's been
quite a significant and unexpected
bounce back in in development management
activity so um
that will
also increase the income beyond what we
were expecting so
which is all good news because it shows
that uh we are getting back to normal
rapidly hopefully
can't council people did you have
another question
i was just going to comment on that and
clearly as you say positive variance is
infinitely better than one in the other
direction but
one was a bit concerned about the
forecasting because clearly absorbing
another
273 grams worth of work in a year is
quite considerable
issue and perhaps the alternative is
that that work gets delayed and that
wouldn't do our reputation
it's just a matter of questions but
thanks for your comment
councilmellon
thank you chair um a couple of questions
on the capital programme from the table
on page 29 of the report
um we've got a budget of 932 000 for the
disabled facilities grants and then
another
269 000 for empty homes grant what's our
ability or capacity to spend this money
in this year
that's the whitehead
thank you um again i'd like to just
refer um that question to our officers
if
i may
gavin
thank you chair um thank you for the
question um so just in relation to um
dfg disabled facilities grants um
members will be aware that uh last year
uh both babur mid suffolk and suffolk
authorities introduced an independent
living service this was to replace the
former
orbit home improvement agency contract
and
if you recall
most recently the out turn from last
year
we actually were able to spend more than
98 of the budget
which was a huge increase on our
previous years and that was only on the
basis of a few months of the the new
service being uh introduced and the
independent living service means that
we've got
officers working on behalf of paper
mid-suffolk that are supporting uh
individuals that need adaptations
and using
new policies and new procedures that uh
cabinet have historically agreed
in relation to
minor works and and some of the values
so
we're confident that that dfg spend will
be spent um and i think actually uh
for cabinets and for members um they'll
probably be tough decisions in the
future as to actually all of that
expenditure being committed and and how
do we look to support those individuals
that uh still require adaptations
in relation to empty home grants
they're grants available to
obviously owners of properties
we are seeing an uptake on some of those
those loans available
and
office
cabinet and members may not be fully
aware but we are in the current process
of
recruiting to a new uh revised private
sector offer which
involves um an officer dedicated to
working with landlords to to encourage
the uptake of these grants and and loans
so i would expect to see a huge progress
uh made over the remainder of uh this
year and and next
thank you gavin
right
we can move into debate now so um
you want to respond to oh yes okay
certainly counselor arthur go ahead okay
yeah i mean he's moving at the same time
prompted by councillor fields question
really and i don't want to steal the
thunder of the portfolio holder for me
to suffolk um but it was just about um
councillorfield's comment about workload
um and he's absolutely right um
the the principal reasons for both the
baber um variance of around about 300
000 and the mid-suffolk one which i
think is about 270. the principal
reasons for that are major applications
so in baber it's woolsey grange that's
come in and in mid-suffolk it's the
various solar farm application fees
part of that is in mid-suffolk but
because the majority of of one of them
is in mid-suffolk mid-suffolk actually
get the fee
so that's that's the reason for the
variance
thank you council marathi
so um baby cabinet members we're in
debate now does anyone wish to say
anything or contribute
um comment on on the uh this report
if not
mid-suffolk members does anyone wish to
comment on the mid-suffolk report
in which case then
we can go to the vote please henriette
thank you
um
and sorry baba members your vote is now
in progress too
[Music]
sorry i'm going to do a reverse order
this time so for mid suffoc uh the vote
is nine votes for and that's unanimous
thank you
counselor busby
have you voted
yeah about 12 times but it doesn't seem
to get to the confirm stage may i take
your vote please yep it was four
uh chair so that is eight votes four and
that's unanimous two thank you henry
moving on item nine
paper bca2119 and mca2118
the housing revenue account financial
monitoring 2021 to 22 quarter one
i'll now introduce the report as the
baby cabinet member for finance
so i'm pleased now to introduce report
bca 2119 to cabinet the hra quarter one
financial monitoring for this year
covering the revenue and capital
financial performance for the period
april to june 2021 and highlighting the
major variances compared with the budget
that are to be expected
as with the general fund it incorporates
the up-to-date impact of kerbin 19 on
the council's hra finances
the headline at the end of quarter one
is that we are forecasting an adverse
variance of 223 000 pounds
as always the financial position of the
hre should be reviewed in the context of
the updated 30-year business plan the
budget set in february uh this year
showed a forecast surplus position for
21 to 22 of 127 000 pounds
and we should always remember that there
will be unplanned events that affect
income and expenditure in any given year
and so we must consider these annual
variances in the context of the
medium-term outcomes we wish to see
we're now in the second of five years
where we can increase rents by cpi plus
one percent
there's still going to be a covert
impact on the hra throughout this year
and new building repairs and maintenance
have restarted but with additional
covered related costs
there will also be additional costs to
address the repairs and maintenance
backlog
there's not been any reduction in income
levels during the first quarter of 21 to
22
but we could start to see arrears when
the furlough scheme comes to an end this
month as tenants who are in employment
may be impacted however levels of debt
to be written off are expected to be
very low if any as any outstanding rates
are likely to be reclaimed or be over a
longer period because of secure
tendencies
the revenue position is detailed in
section 6 of the report and the table in
paragraph 6.5 lists the main items in
the budget along with the variations on
expenditure and income compared with
budget
descriptions of the variances are
provided in paragraph 6.6 to 6.10 and
the main contributor is the adverse
variance of 267 000 pounds for building
services and this is explained in
paragraph 6.9
the forecast variances will be taken
into account sitting next year's budget
all this means that our hra balances are
forecast to be
16.673 million pounds at the end of the
year as detailed in paragraph 6.10
as i mentioned in the general fund
introduction with complex capital
schemes it is difficult to accurately
assess the level of payments that will
be made during the financial year
the important thing is to focus on
whether outcomes have been achieved by
the capital investment rather than
in-year variances
the capital program is itemized in
appendix a and further detail provided
in paragraph 611-614 of the report
actual capital expenditure for
expenditure for quarter one totals 3.12
million pounds against a budget of 27.61
million pounds
we are expecting the full year capital
spend to be equal to the budget but it
is unlikely to be fully spent based on
past experience
before opening up for questions and
debate i'd first like to move the
recommendations in section 3 of the
report that the adverse variance of 223
000 pounds and revised capital program
be noted
may i have a second for this please
councillor osborne thank you
i'll now invite the mid-suffolk cabinet
member for finance to introduce the
mid-suffolk report councillor whitehead
thank you chairman
i'd now like to make a brief
introduction to report mca 2118
which is a housing revenue account
financial monitoring for twenty one
twenty two quarter one the budget for
this current year 2122
showed a surplus of 102 000
however we are now anticipating a
deficit for the year
452 000 an adverse turnaround or
variance of 554 000
the table in paragraph 6.5 shows that
the principal driver of this venus is a
predicted cost overrun in building
services
all other income and expense streams
show minimal change from budget of 1
or less
paragraph 6.10
provides the explanation for this
adverse variance in building services
as we emerge from the kobit restrictions
there is a backlog of void and
responsive repairs to be undertaken
the forecast of the year end assumes a
significant use of subcontractors to
support the trades team in completing
this work
it's my hope that the forecasted adverse
various six ninety thousand in this area
will prove to be an overprudent estimate
but only time will tell
this report also covers the hra capital
programme and the detail is in appendix
a with covering narrative in paragraph
612-615
table shows a low level of actual
capital spend during the first quarter
at 1.564 million
and although the table suggests the
catch up to the
39.959 million budget by the year end
paragraph 6 15 in our report
includes a note of realism that this is
unlikely to be the case
we will of course as usual bring in
further update of forecaster cabinet
based on the half year and three quarter
year actuals in due course
which should provide a clearer picture
of both the revenue spend on repairs and
maintenance and actual capital spend as
the year progresses
the financial position is merely for
noting at this early stage and i'd like
to move the recommendations to that
effect to set out in sections three of
the report
would invite councillor vinnie hadingham
as canada
housing to second those recommendations
thank you
thank you councillor whitehead
so may i have a second information
councillor hattingham thank you
are there any questions
baba members on the baba hra report
is that yeah castle busby yes
thank you chair yet
sorry catherine i still find this
depreciation on um
our housing stock
of interest
we know house values are rising
but we're charging depreciation on them
which is fine except we're also charging
all of the maintenance and repairs into
our account so in theory
the amount that we spend on maintenance
repairs should bring the housing stock
back up to the value that it was
before so what it seems to be like we're
charging the account twice
once for the actual repairs and once for
an estimated
depreciation which there isn't after
we've spent the money
i'll try and answer this but i might
hand over to my finance colleagues if i
get it wrong so they can tell they can
tell me um
the depreciation that we charge into the
housing revenue account we actually can
then use to finance the expenditure
itself
so it's a it's a bit of a quirk and an
anomaly of the housing revenue account
so it is contributing towards how we
finance that actual expenditure as you
say to keep the um the assets up at the
standard that we require them to be
so it's not quite the double charge that
i think you you were thinking it is used
to pay for that maintenance
does appear in here twice doesn't it or
is it only on this but not in the
accounts
it goes through a a reserve called the
major repairs reserve i believe i've
seen some nods in front of me so it goes
from there into the reserve and then we
use that reserve to fund the expenditure
to keep the the assets up to standard
thank you though
guarantee that i won't ask about the
appreciation again at least until next
time
thank you council of basketball that's
um
that's good um any other questions from
baber if not
mid suffolk any questions from mid
suffolk members
no
any questions from
three non-cabinet mid-suffolk members on
the castle field
thank you
try another comment if councillor busby
understands that
hopefully explain it to me someday
um seriously the question uh about
building services we have um 658 um
spend there for reasons that are
explained
um
one was wondering is it possible to pay
that from the the kovid reserve
in one case
or is there some other underspender as
this is delayed work presumably there's
money we didn't spend
previously to fund that
really the question is about the covert
reserve
that's a white head
well that's that's an interesting
question i mean my first initial
reaction is to think that some of the
the actual repairs and
void work that's needed it is not
effectively covered or related although
i take your point that the um
deferral and then the catching up is
sort of
co-related but um i think i'll just pass
that over to
our finance officers to see what their
thoughts on it are
thank you councillor whitehead yeah i
think it's possibly the the latter that
you were saying because if you remember
from the out turn from last year there
was quite a big underspend on the
capital programme so we didn't need the
revenue contribution so
we're trying to catch up on what didn't
get spent last year so that money has
actually been put into the strategic
priorities reserve rather than the
kovidge reserves so it's still sitting
within mid-suffolk's hra reserve
balances and can be used for future
expenditure
thank you
gavin did you want to come back on that
thank you chair um this might not be the
precise answer to the question that
councillor field um asks but i think it
it adds value
to the conversation at this point um
the whole housing sector inevitably saw
a huge wave of of new uh work uh coming
down the track as a result of the three
lockdowns last year and the inability
for any housing service to carry out
what we'd call sort of responsive
repairs uh separate to the emergency
works that we undertook
um just to give uh cabinets and members
an overview of some of the work that is
actually going on at present to to
remedy the situation because clearly
what we don't want our tenants waiting
long times for repairs that require
work
so
initially triaging repairs uh
prioritizing which repairs
need to be carried out
and that's being done by officers within
the building services team and we've
adjusted a lot of the comms on the
website in relation to when to report
repair how to report or repair the types
of repairs and so on um we did a lot of
work last year in terms of uh social
media in the video as well uh to support
tenants at that stage
we are using subcontractors um
inevitably if anyone has had
any attempt to get building work done to
their own property you'll know how hard
it is to find subcontractors but we have
got some some reliable subcontractors
that we've had a relationship with for a
long time and we are utilizing them
wherever possible
in relation to both the responsive
repairs and the voids we've seen an
uptake in in the number of voids as well
we are providing some overtime
opportunities for existing uh operatives
tradespeople within our team to conduct
works on saturdays to to play catch up
and on uh separate to that on based on
separate business cases we have actually
employed additional trades people over
the past 12 months
to
effectively
support the team increase the the
long term reduce the dependency
on subcontractors
we are shortly uh within the next two
months installing scheduling software
that will give officers within the
customer access point
and later tenants the opportunity to uh
book the repair and book the time and
the date that that repair is carried out
and and the reality is that that will
improve productivity um we're actively
working with uh travis perkins our
material main
material supplier
and that's in relation to obviously the
cost of materials
and the supply of materials which has
been a significantly impacted
as i know everyone will know
we've also introduced a new way of
working which prevents operatives having
to go to travis perkins to pick up
materials and actually materials are
delivered on-site
alleviating some of that time and
obviously co2 emissions in terms of
driving around the estates
we've also
seen a number of properties returned to
us that require substantial works
through voids
and we're obviously actively working on
repairing those but also looking at a
new letable standard
which will set out the expectations that
uh incoming tenants can expect new
tenants can expect from us in terms of
the quality of homes
and then just a couple more we've also
got a project that we've embarked on
around in relation to new ways of
working and how the building surfaces
team in light of covid in light of the
the pandemic and how it's impacted on on
every uh sector uh how we work
differently um in the future um and
lastly
we are also in the process of trying to
let
a series of long-term contracts um it is
more cost-effective and more planned
if we can have contracts in place rather
than responding
and therefore we're letting a series of
five-year contracts for a variety of
different types of of building services
which oddly will reduce cost as well
thank you gavin
that's great thank you
right um so now
i'll open this up for debate um baby
members
do any of you wish to
comment on this report
mid-suffolk members
in which case i'll ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on both apps
um
counselor davis
right may i take your vote verbally
please
sorry four thank you
chair so that is eight votes four for
paper that's unanimous
thank you
and it's nine votes for for mid suffolk
and that's also unanimous thank you
henriette
right um there'll now be a short break
to allow officers for the next item to
be seated
so if we turn off the
live stream for a few minutes please
all right welcome back everyone the next
item is item 10 paper bca2120 and mca
2119
the quarter one performance presentation
i'll now invite the baby cabinet member
for customers digital transformation and
improvement to introduce the baba report
council mccraw
thank you chair um
members i'm pleased to
introduce the court at one performance
report for weber district council
to be followed by council of morley
introducing the relevant parts for mid
suffolk
the report is in the same format as we
have seen recently
i'd like to draw attention beyond uh
just particularly to the first paragraph
regarding the successful nominations in
the iese awards that our housing team
have been celebrating they've been
shortlisted for a national award by a
local government magazine and that
success in the community heroes of the
year category recognized the team's
efforts in keeping vulnerable residents
off the streets during the pandemic as
well as the transformation of a derelict
property in sudbury it's literally over
a weekend like so
this is a high level report so i'm going
to
draw attention to some of the highlights
in that report if i can find my papers
so the report reflects and the papers
reflect the continued support and
assistance that we've offered in the
recovery from the pandemic together with
information on the progress made against
our six key priority areas predominantly
from april through to june
the key indicators in the deaf separate
departments and members might like to
ask individual questions of the cabinet
members
in economy
a bid to level up the funding for bus
junctions in sudbury
the successful launch of the extension
of the virtual high street in hadley 50
businesses having signed up to the
scheme and i believe this might be
reflected elsewhere in the area
a sign off of an employment site at
hadley
in environment we've seen a continual
increase in the number of garden waste
subscribers over 16 000 subscriptions
now and for the first time ever we've
collected a thousand tons of garden
waste in june
the wenham depot decarbonisation project
is on schedule
the leisure centers for both councils
have transferred to green tariffs and uh
we're we're we're hopeful of
improvements in the fly tipping
situation although it is one of those
things that can go up and down
on the customers portfolio i think it's
probably something i should comment on
uh i'm very glad to say that 50 searches
the top 50 searches on our website have
been gone through
uh to improve the responses
we were not getting accurate responses
that were directing people in the right
place we now think that that is the case
and those 50 i can provide a breakdown
for anybody that's interested
uh
our new e-forms are receipt are
receiving a satisfaction rating from
customers as 4.6 out of five and this is
probably to reflect that a lot of the
cases were basically where
we had a satisfaction rating given on
the fact that uh the bin hadn't been
collected now that wasn't actually a
satisfaction question that was the
response was being dealt with so it was
inaccurate
uh in communities we have capital
projects helped to fund preston
mary village hall nudging with norton
village hall extension and the pinewood
community center car park refurbishment
the leisure sport physical activity
action plans and strategies are being
developed in both councils
in well-being sudbury easter holiday
activities saw nine families take
advantage of a family cooking project
that's a 90 percent take up since there
were only 10 slots available and 17
children attended adventure days
uh there are other matters going on in
fly in in well-being uh was work being
done with the youth social prescribing
framework and we're working in
partnership with the tobacco control
alliance again in both councils to
reduce smoking and vaping within the
workplace as well as with other
businesses in the district
in housing 19 new affordable homes have
been acquired or built during quarter
one
and ten new homes have also been handed
over at woolsey grange in sprawton
there's a case study on the my home
bulletin which is in your papers
and then the final item i was going to
mention actually it's not the final item
is the health of the organization we've
completed some letting of land at the
south suffolk business center for use
for the go start community buses one
thing i do have to mention is
a increase in the length of time it is
taking for us to answer phone calls
it's something that occupies members
attention every time it comes up and the
reason is higher call volumes but the
call volumes is not just the the rate of
them it's the complexity of them we saw
a 17 increase uh to 600 calls per day
as an average which means that the peaks
were higher and the sort of questions
were more complex requiring well things
like council tax recovery
responsive repairs the backlog
also was reflected in
our customer service provision
so we have a higher waiting time than we
would like steps have been taken to hire
more staff and train those staff so that
they can become as effective as the rest
of our customer services team already
are um obviously i'll be happy to take
any questions on the various parts of
that and i'll hand over to council
morley
thank you council macro
so um this item is for noting only but
i'll now then pass over to
the mid-soccer cabinet member for the
same portfolio casamali
thank you as you will see the
performance reporting for quarter one
has continued to follow the revised
format
allowing for reporting of key
performance indicators and information
on the work being undertaken by our
district
providing high level assurance that the
council is delivering against our
corporate plan
i would like to take this opportunity to
mention some of the key achievements and
performance indicators within the
presentation to highlight not only the
progress being made on a number of key
projects
but also as a reflection of the
continued commitment of all officers and
councillors in striving to achieve our
strategic outcomes and ensure effective
recovery from the
kobe pandemic
so on
economy we've commenced the work at the
needham lake visitor center that is now
well underway
the successful launch of the extension
to the virtual high street project in
rolled out in stone market and more
recently in need and market and die
for environment we've seen an incre
continual increase in the number of
garden waste subscribers
and this has
led to a record
1122 tonnes of garden waste being
collected in june
however there's also been an increase in
the contamination of recycling waste
collected
and this has increased to 16.67
we've also acquired some key
biodiversity land in stone market as
part of our carbon reduction plan
councilman mccrory has already mentioned
top searches on the on our website
especially around the new
electronic forms that our customers are
really rating quite highly
on communities
our capital projects have helped fund
grants for new play equipment at
codename community centre
along with developing community space at
a church in stone market
and our leisure sport and physical
activity strategy has now gone through
cabinet and we are now developing the
action plan
for well-being our easter holiday family
cooking school saw a take-up of over 90
at both stone market and i with well
over 60 children also attending the
adventure days
holiday activity funding was awarded to
a number of venues in stone market to
deliver summer activities targeted at
children in receipt of free school meals
housing there's been a reduction in the
number of housing households requiring
temporary accommodation
however we do have some voids
which are at 33 days which is higher
than our target
and there are some some good reasons for
these
there are a number of properties that
required using right to buy receipts
which required extensive work such as
kitchens bathrooms
and rewiring ahead of letting
and we also had voids resulting from
tenancies where people had lived there a
long time
and properties that we received back
were in a very poor condition
needing lots of work to bring them up to
standard so this is
while the majority of properties in
mid-support were completed within the 21
days
these properties
which required the additional works went
well over the number of days and
therefore pushed up the average
there were 42 housing specific planning
applications granted which would deliver
290 homes
and
also
pure gym has now opened its premises at
gipping way in stone market this is on
the site of the former aldi
thank you council award sir
the performance report
thank you castle molly um again that
item is for noting only but now i'll
open it up to uh for questions so
firstly questions from baylor members do
you have any questions on this
report
casarati
um it's a comment more than a question i
suppose
but it's regarding fly tipping
and you'll see in the report that
there's been a reduction of 50 percent
but if you go to page 49 you'll see what
the trend is
and particularly in baber
we saw a 100
increase during the kobit period
and now we're reporting a 50 reduction
just to be clear
a 100 increase followed by a 50
reduction means that we're back to where
we were
so it's not actually an improvement
really
it's just a returning to the
sort of average number of fly tips that
we've seen
um
and can i make a
can i carry on with wait times for calls
um just that last week i had a personal
experience
we talk here about
wait times as an average
just to be sure about this that average
is obviously
has extremes at one end and the other
and last week i was actually on the
phone for 12 minutes waiting um and then
i had to call back about half an hour
later and it was 15 minutes
before
i was connected so these wait times can
be quite significant
to be fair that was for council tax
which is actually not a labour or
mid-suffolk service because it's um done
through ipswich borough council under
the shared revenues partnership however
i still think that waiting over 10
minutes for somebody to connect you is
too long
thank you counselor
[Music]
and that wasn't me
so where that came from thank you for
that um uh council davis
you can you can save for debate in a bit
if you want to but uh
okay
okay yeah
um
carson busby
uh environment one of our objectives is
to plant trees and it says that one of
the things that we'll be doing over the
next few months is planting trees over
the winter months
how many trees and where will we be
planting them
uh castlevania do you have an answer for
that
thank you very much chair and thank you
councillor busby um we're gathering the
data we've just completed a canopy
survey of the trees in mid-african and
babur
and that data is currently being
collated unfortunately the individual
that
was doing it is off sick at the moment
but we are on track we should be able to
come to cabinet with more information by
the end of this month beginning of next
where they're planted will depend on not
just where there is space but whether or
not the parish councils and town
councils want that tree
where we're suggesting because they're
being asked to identify
their land
their land owners land that is willing
to receive these trees and hedgerows
thank you councillor
okay um now we'll move to mid-suffolk
any questions from mid-suffolk members
any questions from other myths so
councillor welland
[Music]
i think
okay well um unexplained noises are
probably a feature of uh this meeting
today um we'll just have to proceed and
uh work our way through them councillor
welland yes thank you chair um
my two questions are about the women's
tour on needham lake
um
reading on page 60 the women's tour
activity will be planned between july
and september as tour details are
announced
when when we would be provided what with
details of what's going on in mid
suffolk in connection with the women's
tour i believe that there is something
in stone market going on but
we really need to advertise any activity
to promote the women's tour coming
through our our district
and
in order to do so i think we need to use
village magazines and copy dates for
village magazines are probably about now
or just gone i mean in the case of
advertising anything or promoting
anything in stone auckland a copy date
is the 7th of september for the october
magazine after october it's too late and
similarly about needham lake
um
i asked i asked
about this last month
do we haven't opened an opening date yet
um
our activities for the public being
planned
for the opening date
and when can we be given details so we
can publish them publicizing locally
thank you councillor
council richardson can you provide
responses thank you
oh there we go i think that's better
thank you chair i can answer the first
question about the women's tour and so
we've we've got a or we are in the final
stages of putting together a community
activity plan that works with not just
ourselves but with the county council
town parish councils other businesses
and community groups to help publicize
and to mark that event so i appreciate
when this paper was published which
would have been more than a week ago
that was still saying we are planning to
do that but we are we have now completed
that so there was a briefing to myself
and the cabinet member for communities
uh last
wednesday i think it was and that
outlined what that is so that that piece
of work is now done and we'll be
publicizing that in the coming days
thank you chair
thank you and in terms of the
sorry
casino oh you
you can provide some further update can
you okay and
cancel well councilman mario castle
flatman who wishes to well i'm just
going to say that
we did do a press release on the 21st of
july
that went out that actually um
said what the route was going to be so
that may help
the
press release in july um highlighting
the route
uh so that has been uh all members have
been been informed about the actual
route um that that'll take through mid
suffolk and baba
that was published last uh back in july
well absolutely because i asked
questions about it last month um
people know people all over the country
know where the route is um
but what we don't know is
what
community activities have been planned i
mean i would
i i know that there are there are
schools that would like to go and see
the cyclists go through
but we don't well and i know that it
comes along finger on it comes past
but i understood there were there were
activities planned for the recreation
ground
well
you know it's about it's about now or a
couple of months ago that
we needed to know
what it is on the recreation ground and
where it is on the recreation ground and
what you know what sort of activities is
it appropriate for um i mean i
understand that there's a plan to
publicize it
but
i don't know how
how you're planning to publicize it but
quite often for events that
affect or
to which people living in villages might
be invited the best way to to get them
invited is through the village magazines
and most of the village magazines go to
print
first first 10 days of september
for delivery
in time for october
council flatman did you want to come
back and provide any further information
please
um well i had a meeting with sue calver
the other day and she's she's the
officer working on this and she will be
in touch um and if you've got the uh the
actual
um tour coming through your village then
she will actually be in touch with the
cabinet member at the member
council member for that for that village
so i know she's actually putting it
together as we speak
um
but that's all i don't know if vicky
knows anymore
yep um thank you very much for the for
the question there is a vast program of
activity taking place and um councillor
flatman's uh correct that sue carver has
been working with town and parish
councils um and with schools as well in
terms of what activities will be taking
place we're also working alongside the
county council with regards to campaigns
so for example with schools there'll be
things like a t-shirt competition where
children invited to
design t-shirts around
the tour
um so that program of activities now
being signed off is part of a much wider
um activity and program with county
council as well so we will look to seek
and make sure that is circulated as soon
as possible and if we can do that we
will do that this week
thank you vicky um council flatman did
you want to answer the question about
needham lake
thank you
um yes
progressing nicely
i'm not um about to tell you the date
yet that we are absolutely going to be
finished because as you know materials
are a little bit hard to come by at the
moment but we are doing very very well
and we are hoping it will be um
well watch this space but i'm not going
to give you a date because i can't
guarantee that's going to happen but
it's all underway and yes that will be
well publicized what we're going to do
to you know attract people down there
for the opening etcetera
thank you councillor
right if there are no further questions
we'll move into debate um councilman
crawl do you want to it's just a comment
on the woman's tour there's quite an
extensive web page on the women's tour
with all ever with connections for
community activities and guidelines so
i'm pretty sure it can be pulled
together very easily
i just happen to know that sweet spot
normally would the organizers of the
british of the women's tour and the
men's tour of britain yeah um have
obviously normally they'd have done all
this stuff um in the eighth spring
but in the spring it was impossible to
say whether the tour
or the tours could run
so some time has been lost that's not
made things easy
no i understand that um just to remind
everyone we are looking back over the
past three months not not looking
forward uh either to this quarter the
current court order or the future
quarters so this is just a review of the
first quarter of this year um councillor
david you wanted to um
across anybody else but the individual
towns and villages for example this is
long melford have already started
because as julius said sue calver has
been to um to the various places and
helped
the parish councils and i'm sure exactly
the same in glensfield i know um because
that's part of the sprint stage and the
queen in the mountains so they've done
an awful lot of work but sue is the
person to do that and also there's a
media cycle on friday
and at the end of that obviously
there'll be more publicity
and as harry has said it's suffolk
county council that are leading on that
part of it and so various towns need to
sort of focus on the road but the
general information will come further
from that as well and then there's a
public ride um later on as well so the
publishing is being ramped up um
literally day by day
that's that's just on the on the right
um but the the
comment i was going to make was to
actually um say two thank yous first of
all to the community's team for
everything that they've been doing with
this and everything else you've seen
it's all positive stuff and it's it's
great to be able to see this so
yeah well done working with his team on
that and also well done to the members
because we we know the problems over the
past couple of years about briefings and
members feeling they haven't been
informed well enough so for the amount
of members to turn up to the health and
well-being of the community grants
review
briefing workshop that was held by vicky
and the team was great because
that's the way you know all the members
can get that further information to be
able to take back to their villages and
parishes and towns so yeah well done to
all the members that turned up for that
and you know a huge well done to vicky
and her team for putting this and the
report together
thank you councillor
cancer osborne
thank you mr chairman um i'm really
pleased to see that 99 fly tips have
been cleared in 48 hours i think that's
great performance
however and it is a big however
flight timing is a concern to to members
and to our residents it's a very high
priority as far as they're concerned and
we're concerned
and
i would rather that we
looked at prevention rather than cure
cure is very very expensive very costly
whereas prevention long term would work
out a lot cheaper um and also not just
on the bigger sites where we get
commercial fly tipping but also on our
own developments where you just get the
occasional mattress or the occasional
old unused barbecue left for collection
and i really would like to see more
prevention going on in this area the
other thing is i know i appreciate we're
looking back rather than forward but i
really want to take this opportunity
to
say about the um 21 units that have
become available angel court
despite covid it's been achieved nearly
on target i understand that all the
rented properties have now been
allocated and there's a big take-up for
the few shared ownership that there are
there but it was really it's a great
effort and i know it's been appreciated
by those people that are going to be
living there we had a
handed over the keys a couple of weeks
ago
and the quality of the build is is very
very good and it's a real example of
where baba is going to with their
housing development program so well done
to all and also just quickly is the
eight coming forward in shockley very
very soon they'll be advertised as being
um
going onto gateway for allocation
there's an example of not just going in
and repairing voids but looking at the
sites there were two sites with
bungalows on and instead of um uh
repairing the two buildings on there we
knocked them down and instead of two
bungalows we've now got four on each
side so there again it's it's a good way
that baber are looking at a proactive
way to deliver housing for our local
communities so thank you mr chairman
thank you council osborne and um uh i'd
like to concur the the flight clear-up
rate is excellent um it's all part and
parcel of our really good waste service
that we provide to our residents
council melvici
thank you very much chairman um just to
come back to councillor osborne's um
concern over flight tipping
we're currently pulling together a
litter and fly tipping strategy
in baber
and we would draw attention to the case
study and how to report fly tipping
because of course people that fly tip
for some reason don't know that they are
flight tipping
they're quite surprised fly tipping is
leaving waste even around bottle banks
and clothing banks um and other such
waste collection points where maybe the
container is full and the individual
with the waste
just drops it by the side
so we're in the process of recruiting a
waste management officer
and last week we had discussions where
we
we actually felt that this individual
should be going around schools and
explaining what fly tipping is
because if the children are embarrassed
at what their parents do we're more
likely to succeed
because the parents will find an excuse
whether it's an excuse for parking
incorrectly or for fly tipping
whatever they will find an excuse
promise they won't do it again
but they will
thank you councillor thank you thank you
um if there are no further comments from
baylor i just got a couple of things i
just wanted to mention myself the
the 15.15
um
contaminated recycling material is is
still too high and i think
um
we do need to see if we can have a
another program of publicity and
education around that because i'm sure
people don't
some of it's accidental some of it may
be deliberate but a lot may be down to
people just not not realizing what can
and can't go in in the blue bins
um and uh castle malvisi your point
about um schools again a campaign in
schools just to remind the children of
what what is recyclable and or and what
isn't i think would help there
considerably
the other point i wanted to to mention
was the the garden waste subscription
service
um we've seen a further increase it is
proving to be incredibly popular
uh
my only comment is not really for
members here but actually for the
government please don't interfere with
the garden waste service it's working
very well
i have passed that information to to my
mp and i hope that
ultimately it will be heard um
at higher levels because
we don't want them to do anything that
that would
interfere with that service with and and
leave it up to us
as local authorities at a local level to
provide the kind of service and and
the charging for that service that we
think fits our own district
however we'll wait and see
um i'll move over now to mid suffolk uh
any members uh
suffolk wish to comment on this
sorry councillor fleming
yes thank you very much um
i just thought i'd mention
two things um one is on the fly tipping
um
we did have a successful prosecution
recently which was in the paper but the
fine was only a thousand pounds
and that's way too low
unless something is done to
increase the
approach by the judiciary to the problem
then
you know it really does
dishearten our offices and and all the
effort that goes into
into the very difficult job of putting
together the piece of information taking
them to court and the very high level
evidence that's needed in order to
successfully prosecute i i don't know
this also is probably a message to mps
but but that's a ridiculously low fine
the other thing i wanted to mention
about garden waste contamination that
there is a trend
and i'm not saying it's necessarily in
suffolk
but where garden waste collection is
free the rate of contamination is higher
than if it's subscribed
thank you councilman foaming that's a
very um uh useful observation there
about the garden waste
council richardson
thank you very much chair uh i just
wanted to to briefly uh mention that i
completely endorse everything that
councillor davis said about our
communities team
i think they've done a fantastic job
over the last few months not just in
responding to the needs of the community
during the lockdown but also in all of
the initiatives both across the
communities and well-being portfolios
that they've been working on and as has
been mentioned quite rightly there's a
lot of positive news stories um in this
in this report and on top of all of that
there's obviously been the production um
and now completion of the well-being
strategy which got an
enormous amount of very positive
feedback when it came to a all member
briefing on thursday of last week so as
much as there has been some some great
progress over the last
financial quarter i think we'll see that
continue and in fact we'll build on that
with the new well-being strategy so i
think it's a very very exciting um
exciting time and again councilwood i
think you mentioned this in another
respect but it's definitely a case of
i've watched this space i think thank
you chad thank you
council brewster
thank you chair
um yes just looking at the economy uh
work that's that's been going on um
obviously everyone can read what's there
but there's an awful lot going on um
including the kober grant funding which
36
million and just in excess of 500 000
there
which included economy it included
finance
srp
quite quite a big team
and i really applaud them for the work
they've done there
but having said that
obviously the work has still been going
on but i'm sure that the teams
will be happy that they've now come to
the end of the
funding the government funding
to
to go out to businesses
and be able to get on with their day
jobs
which i know they wanted to do
and
did succeed in doing some of it as well
or quite a lot of it
um
i think councilor maury mentioned the
virtual high street in in her opening
and
in stone market the 60
businesses which have signed up for it
and i suspect that is actually grown
since this report came out
and also know
i and nida market are
are having
uh getting ready for the virtual high
street which will be launched very very
soon i understand
i did ask fiona if if she'd got any
increased figures just just to
demonstrate what what work is going on
there
yes i have i've got some uh
additional figures i think you just
quoted 60 in stone market for the
virtual high street it's actually now
80. um and
i has gone up to 16 businesses signed up
and needham 10 and as you know we
haven't really yet moved into a
sustained campaign in needham so they a
lot of those have been uh sort of
anecdotal and just while i'm talking i
mentioned the baba figures as well which
is 152 businesses in sudbury which was
the original pilot and 65 in hadley
thank you
thank you for hearing us
um yeah i just wanted to use that as an
example of the work that my team our
team are doing and uh really thank every
single member of that team thank you
thank you council marissa and uh those
numbers for babe are excellent 65 in
hadley and that's a tiny town really
um a population of about 8 000 people
um one one street of uh businesses
pretty much and uh
so uh those those numbers are excellent
and um
i'm sure that all of the participants
do
do value the virtual high street it is
it is um
i i think uh something that's very
exciting for both districts
okay anyone else from mid suffolk wish
to say anything
if not i'll um close this by just saying
that this item is for noting
only
and the next item is a weber only item
so there will now be a short break so
that officers can be seated for that
mid suffix thank you very much for your
attendance
on the baby welcome back to the last
item on the baby agenda
it's item 11 paper bca 2121 adoption of
the revised stable affairs for hackney
carriages i'll now invite the baby
member cabinet member for the
environment to introduce the report
council of lvc
thank you very much chairman i'm very
pleased to bring this
to bring bca
2121 to the cabinet
on the 16th of august
a revised table of fares came back to
the licensing and regulatory committee
following a 28-day consultation with the
trade and the general public
cabinet might remember that the previous
dual table affairs which was adopted on
the 4th of february 2021 was found to be
potentially discriminatory following the
decision
this table was therefore suspended and
the licensing team worked closely with
the trade and other stakeholders to
develop an alternative proposal
the proposed table affairs on which we
have recently consulted is based on
suggestions from drivers operators and
meter agents
the aim is to provide an increased
income for the trade
whilst ensuring
taxi travel is affordable for all and
those who are only able to travel in one
of the larger wheelchair accessible
vehicles are not penalized
it will be an operational decision for
each operator and proprietor whether the
maximums are charged as they have the
discretion to charge less if they so
wish
and a passenger is entitled to attempt
to negotiate a lesser fare
however proprietors must meter the
maximum fares permissible
in the
district maximum fares must be
transparent to the fair paying passenger
and should enable operators to charge
realistic fares
the consultation on the proposed table
affairs ran from the 14th of june to the
12th of july 2021
the statutory public notice was issued
in the east anglian daily times 14th of
june 2021 edition
a notice was posted at the council
offices and notices were placed at the
customer access points within the
district and on the baba website
the consultation documents were posted
to 234
taxi and private hire operators and
drivers
no responses to the consultation were
received from the public
one response was received from the trade
which was supportive of the proposal
can i mention the individual's name
okay it was from a mr steve hale who was
one of the main objectors to the
previous proposal
mr hale attended the committee on monday
and with permission of the chair
assisted the committee by answering
questions on the proposed tariff
the committee were also shown some
example journeys to compare the cost
based on the tariff
which is currently in operation
and the proposed tariff which shows that
there is a modest
increase
providing an increased income for the
trade
while still being affordable to
travelers
the committee voted unanimously to
recommend to cabinet to adopt the
proposed table affairs
and that they should come into force on
the 1st of november 2021
the recommendation before you today
are as follows
firstly the cabinet following
consideration of licensing and
regulatory committee's recommendation
adopts the revised table affairs
attached at appendix a to this report
and in accordance with section 65 of the
local government miscellaneous
provisions act 1976
sets the date of 1st november 2021 for
these to come into effect
and secondly that the cabinet quashes
the resolution made on the 4th of
february to adopt the table of
the table affairs which were previously
recommended by licensing and regulatory
committee
and the other thing i would draw your
attention to
is that
these fares have not been revised for
five years
thank you very much
thank you councilman rbc may i have a
second uh
council arthi thank you
are there any questions
from paper members council
yeah thank you mr chairman can i just
clarify those rates that are outlined in
um appendix a of this report
is that the maximum that can be charged
although
that's the maximum is it that could be
charged so although this discretion in
the charge is being made they've those
charges can't be exceeded is that am i
right
correct
thank you thank you mr chairman
any other questions
okay um
we'll move into debate does anyone from
babel want to say anything about this
report um it's
councillor
halt first and then customer
yeah thank you i'd just like to sort of
sum up the whole thing really i mean
it's the third time lucky for us i mean
this is first brought to you guys in
june 20 i believe
and i don't think it puts us in a good
light that we're here in um
september 21 discussing the same topic
and i think there's lessons to be
learned probably from members officers
as a collective on the way we approach
this sort of thing in the future because
i think it's it's generally it's been a
little bit embarrassing to the district
council
i'm glad to see it coming to an end and
fully support the paper we have in front
of us
um but that's what i wanted to say thank
you thank you council hall
councillor arthur
yeah i don't disagree with council holt
actually that we've learned something
from this but we seem to have got there
in the end
so i'm happy to support it thank you
councillor davis
yeah um
as you know i voted against it last time
i wasn't happy with the whole thing so
i'm delighted that it's gone back
to licensing and i'm delighted they've
had further consultation with the taxi
drivers and the operators and that yeah
we have finally
come to a resolution and i'm fully
endorsing this but i agree with the
other councillors you know we've learned
something from it yeah let's make sure
that we don't allow this sort of thing
to happen again
yeah um uh i would i would concur with
uh that um and everything that's been
said um and but also i think um
we've got there in the end and uh i
would like to thank uh mr hale and the
other operators for bearing with us and
for
working with us to to get to where we
are now and also thank emma um for the
work that she's put into this and um
we've got what i think is a good good
report here good good new
um
set of tariffs which will provide the
operators with some much needed
additional income after all it hasn't
been revised for many years now so um i
think
we're good on this one
there are no other comments then we'll
move into the vote now there's going to
be a separate vote on the two
recommendations and the first one to
quash the the decision that was made in
february and the second one will be the
the new substantive recommendation for
for this report
so if i'll allow the governance officer
to open up the vote please
members your vote is now in progress on
your app
for the first recommendation
chair that is eight votes for that's
unanimous thank you
recommendation
chair that is eight votes for and that's
unanimous thank you henry
oh thank you everyone that brings
today's meeting to a close and
the next meeting is monday 4th of
october at 10 30.
so
bring the meeting
you